hello everyone and welcome back to the
things the Louds may seem like a
fictional family but they border on
reality we've compiled a list of
real-life families who could pass as the
Louds any day of the week we just go to
sleep if you think your family is loud
and chaotic then wait until you lay your
eyes on the last family on our list we
know that all of you are pretty big fans
of Lincoln and his ten sisters the loud
house show produced by Nickelodeon has
brought us many relatable characters but
that's not all it turns out that the
show was actually inspired by animator
Chris savino's life and family the show
takes place in a fictional town in
Michigan called royal woods the name of
the area takes after the name of
savino's actual hometown of Royal Oak
the plot of the series was pitched by
Savino since he grew up in a pretty
large family himself he is the ninth
child out of 10 children his siblings
consisted of four brothers and five
sisters for a total of five boys and
five girls in his family Savino even
named the characters Laurie Lisa Lynn
Louanne and Lana after his very own
sisters considering that the average
family has about two children we
definitely know plenty of celebrity
families that exceed that mark by a long
shot
just think of the six-car jenner clan
members and even the eight children of
comedian actor Eddie Murphy when you
think about it that is pretty crazy but
getting here wasn't easy but nothing
compared to the families on this list so
let's get started the bonell family the
bonell family is made up of 16 members
and surprisingly they aren't ruling out
the possibility of a 17 they live in
Queensland Australia and their family
consists of nine boys and seven girls
Jenny bonell the mother of the household
mentioned that when she had initially
gotten married she had no intention of
having any children at all all that
supposedly changed after she gave birth
to her first baby boy Jessie who now
says that she has learned to love the
chaos the noise and the hugs and the
other parts of parenthood - the chores
are apparently split between all the
members of the household above the age
of 8 years old the craziest detail of
this family dynamic is perhaps the fact
that bonell drives all of her kids to
school in a 16 cedar mercedes school bus
the launce family the launce family is
made up of 18 mmm
they live in British Columbia Canada but
originally immigrated from Romania in
1990 their last reported child was born
in 2008 the reasoning behind their
decision to start their uniquely large
family seems to be a spiritual one they
mentioned that they decided to leave the
decision of how many children they were
to have up to God this has left them
with eight boys and ten girls to date
despite being offered a ton of lucrative
TV series and documentary contracts the
family has continuously rejected these
offers
they have only appeared in a handful of
interviews and choose to live a more
private and low-key life the Bates
family Gil and Kelly Bates are two
parents who have chosen to embrace the
cameras and not shy away from life on
television the Bates starred on their
very own TV series on up TV this series
featured both parents and their 19
children the family lives in a six
bedroom house which consists of one
guest room and five others for the
personal use of the family with the
parents taking a room to themselves this
leaves just two rooms for the boys and
two rooms for the girls we sure hope
they all get along or that could be a
pretty sticky situation we bet the Louds
are feeling pretty good about themselves
right now the Bell Salak family we've
decided to take it up a notch and bring
you guys a family with no less than 59
children the story behind this family
which makes up 61 members if you factor
in the parents is actually very sweet
and inspiring the father of the family
Jim Silla met his wife and bells and
married her after just four months since
then the couple went on to adopt 59 kids
all of whom are boys not only that but
all of these children knowingly have
some sort of disability which did not
deter the couple in the slightest their
home is equipped with a team of nurses
teachers and aides
all of whom consistently ensure that
everything is running smoothly and that
everyone is being taken care of and
bells even as a keepsake box for each of
the boys the boxes are said to have
pictures and art need by the boys along
with some mementos that they arrived
with she mentions that this is her and
her husband's attempt to piece back the
children's history if that isn't the
sweetest story you've heard all day we
don't know what is the chiana family the
channa family is the largest family on
our list and they live in the village in
India their family consists
39 wives 14 daughters-in-law ninety four
children and 33 grandchildren this leads
to a total of 180 family members they
catch in this family stories that they
all live in one giant four-story mansion
which has a hundred rooms to accommodate
the little village of the family members
this house actually has a name and is
known by the villagers as the house of
the new generation there was once a
documentary made of the family where you
can even spot the family taking turns
doing chores with a large number of them
dedicated to laundry cooking and singing
the family gets along very well and are
very happy to be living under one roof
in the documentary you can spot some of
the children proudly showing the
videographers around the house that they
share many of the women even mentioned
how happy they are to be with their
large and loving family since it's a lot
more interesting than their old and
simple lives the family sustains itself
by growing their very own props and even
establishing their very own school the
family even wakes up and goes to bed
together starting their days at 5:30
a.m. and going to bed at 9:00 p.m. we
imagine that keeping up with this family
takes a ton of work so their schedules
definitely don't surprise us and that's
the end of our video we hope you enjoyed
getting to know these special families
because we know we did Navy Lincoln loud
doesn't have it so bad after all be sure
to subscribe to the things and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching see you guys next
time
[Music]